what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and she-hulk attorney at
law episode one has set up something
major for the hulk's future in the
marvel cinematic universe now before
going into the she-hulk series we knew
that the hulk and bruce banner were
going to be in the show we also heard a
lot of rumors about a possible solo hulk
movie specifically a world war hulk
movie and obviously fans were super
excited about that rumor the hulk
getting his own solo movie and most
importantly the specific rumor that the
movie could be a world war hulk movie
got fans excited that we could see the
hulk rage out again and get a true hulk
not a contained smart hulk as they call
him but a true hulk one that goes
furious with rage that cannot be stopped
and i actually think that marvel studios
could be setting the hulk up to be a
villain at least for one film where the
hulk is completely in charge and bruce
banner has absolutely no control but
it's a full rageful hulk well luckily
for us she-hulk episode 1 gave us many
hints and clues that we are indeed going
to be getting this solo hulk film and
that we are going to be getting a true
hulk in his full on rage form and today
we're going to talk about what the
possible story is going to be in the
hulk solo film and what could cause him
to truly hulk out and lose everything
going full hulk mode so let's dive into
it and of course if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news so as i mentioned and as you've
probably heard before there's a rumor
going around that we could be getting a
solo hulk film and that it could be a
world war hulk solo hulk film it's also
been rumored that the rights to the hulk
have actually gone back to disney and
marvel studios allowing them to make the
solo hulk film and then we saw she-hulk
episode 1 where we saw a cecarian ship
actually caused the crash of jennifer
walters and bruce banner the crash that
would ultimately lead to jennifer
walters becoming she-hulk and later on
bruce banner did address this he said it
was a zakarian spaceship that was
probably trying to deliver a message and
of course the biggest question to that
is who who exactly is trying to deliver
a message to the hulk and he even said
that he has to see what that's about
this is great news because it looks like
this is the setup for that hulk film
however there is one key component that
i think a lot of people are missing in
this episode that does involve the
future hulk film and does involve the
hulk going full rage mode again and that
is the line where the hulk tells his
cousin jennifer walters when people
start seeing you as a monster that
doesn't go away i believe that this line
and another scene that comes later on in
episode 1 are extremely important for
the hulk's future for starters if we are
going to indeed get another hulk film
and if it is going to be centered around
world war hulk and world breaker hulk
the hulk is going to have to rage out
again and he's going to have to become a
monster again i'm not talking about a
hulk where bruce banner has his hands on
the wheel but is in hulk form i'm
talking about where bruce once again
loses control and loses the fight to the
hulk to where the hulk is the one in
charge but more specifically i actually
think that we are starting to see scenes
where bruce banner smart hulk is kind of
starting to get a little bit of rage
inside of him and kind of lose control
just a little bit now in the comics
she-hulk was always more in control than
bruce banner just like they showed us in
episode 1 jennifer walters has always
had the ability to turn from jennifer
into she-hulk kind of at will and
jennifer is always in control she
doesn't have an ego hulk it's always
jennifer of course we know that that
isn't the case for the hulk the hulk has
always been rageful he's always been
super brutal so in episode 1 we actually
see the difference between the two and a
little bit of rage come out of the hulk
when she-hulk and hulk are fighting we
see a relatively in control hulk he's
not really going full out he's not
trying that hard but as she-hulk kind of
starts to get the best of him we
actually see the rage come out and we
actually see him charge at her hit her
and then he yells at her he screams in
hulk form this is something that we
haven't really seen in a while even in
avengers in game and this is a great
sign of where the future of the hulk
could be going more rage now eventually
the hulk is going to have to check out
what that message from sakhar was about
and i believe that he will actually go
back to sakaar here the story can go one
of a few different ways but i think they
all kind of revolve around the hulk
actually having a family here's the deal
world war hulk and planet hulk take
place on sakaar for the most part the
illuminati tricks bruce banner and sends
him off into space until eventually he
lands on sakhar ultimately he ends up
becoming the ruler of zakar he gets a
wife and she is pregnant and then they
are killed the ship that the illuminati
sent the hulk into space in explodes and
therefore the hulk thinks it's the
illuminati's fault that his wife and
unborn child are killed however there
are other comic story lines that show
the hulk actually having a son scar and
here's where things can go one of a few
different ways clearly the hulk is at
somewhat of good terms with the people
at scar after all he was their champion
but he's obviously on good enough terms
for him to return he clearly doesn't
feel that threatened but this is where
things are going to truly have to change
because i believe that the only thing
that's going to really cause the hulk to
freak out again and go into full rage
mode is something pretty traumatic and i
think that it's going to have to be
pretty traumatic to the hulk not bruce
banner but the hulk and that could be
the hulk finding out that he has a son
this could bring the hulk back out again
because if the hulk had a son on zakar
that's the hulk not bruce banner
remember the hulk landed on zakar and he
was in charge the entire time they were
there up until when thor turned the hulk
back to bruce banner so anything that
would have happened on sakhar any kids
that the hulk might have had any women
that the hulk might have been involved
with that's all the hulk not bruce
banner and this is where the conflict
comes in when bruce banner gets back to
sakaar i think the hulk is going to come
out when he meets his son or an old
woman that he used to be with the hulk
is going to want to come back out this
will start the struggle once again
between bruce banner and the hulk and i
think that if something tragic happens
the hulk is just going to hulk out and i
think this goes one of two different
ways one is that something kind of
similar to the comics will happen and
this is where we will get the hulk
actually as a villain and i'm actually
all for this even though it is a tragic
story i am for the hulk going back to
earth as the hulk in rage mode being a
villain being super mad at the avengers
for being the reason that he originally
had to leave and the people of earth for
looking at him like he was a monster
that ultimately led to him going to
sakhar and if his family his son or a
woman that he used to be with are killed
or were killed while he was gone that's
going to make the hulk very angry
especially angry at bruce banner if he
had somewhat of a family on sakhar and
then the hulk turned back to bruce
banner and the hulk went away for a very
long time and didn't let the hulk have
any control whatsoever that kept him
from sakar where he might have been able
to defend his family this would mean the
hulk would actually blame bruce banner
and would go against him and this will
kind of get us back to what i'll call
normal the normal struggle between the
hulk and bruce banner now i don't want
the hulk to lose his family but i would
like to see a full rage mode hulk again
however there is another option in the
comics scar hulk's son actually spends a
good majority of the time trying to kill
the hulk and get revenge on him and
again like i said probably simply seeing
his son would bring out the hulk again
because again it's the hulk son but scar
is a great warrior much like his father
the hulk and this isn't really going to
be a battle that bruce banner could win
as smart hulk so he'll have to go full
rage mode again now knowing marvel and
disney this will probably end with the
two of them actually being on good terms
or setting up another movie where that
will eventually happen but this will
bring the hulk back out and i'm thinking
that he's gonna be kind of pissed off
that banner has held him down and not
let him come out for many many years
over five years that's a pretty long
time and here again is where the fight
between the hulk and banner comes back
this is how we will get the true hulk
once again where we once again have the
struggle between the hulk and bruce
banner fighting to be in control of the
body and here's the thing marvel
typically listens to fans they don't
always do what the fans think is best
but they listen to fans and they take
into consideration what they're saying
they basically take in feedback and for
a very long time a lot of fans have been
talking about how smart hulk isn't
exactly their favorite and they missed
the original hulk and now it seems like
they are very clearly setting up a hulk
story one where the hulk goes back to
sakaar where in the comics and in the
movies he was a great gladiator warrior
in the comics he eventually becomes the
ruler of zakar and i think that's what
we're about to see here in the mcu the
hulk was the champion of zakar the
people loved him and now with smart hulk
bruce banner's mind is in charge and
he's smart enough to outsmart the grand
master if he's even still there so i
think we're about to see the hulk become
the ruler of sakhar and i think the hulk
is about to try to take over again which
will ultimately lead to bruce banner
getting out of the picture and if things
don't go so well we could see the hulk
revolt and be a villain something that i
would actually enjoy seeing and i think
a lot of fans would enjoy as well but
hey let me know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below what
direction do you think they'll take the
solo hulk film in the mcu please don't
forget to like the video as it really
helps in the algorithm don't forget to
subscribe stay up to date on all mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof